c'est la photographie de aux relents
d'une artiste française de très connu
il s'agit de profils de femmes manquent
beytout et profils de femmes euros
stéphanoise une photographie qui date de
2002 et qui appartient à une série de
séries africaines
orlan est une artiste qui a toujours
placé son corps au sens de ses
recherches artistiques son corps c'est
son médium elle a souvent modifiez
transformez en fonction des canons et
critères de beauté dans différentes
civilisations elle a commencé par la
chirurgie esthétique
en transformant son visage en lien avec
des des icônes de la beauté féminine de
la renaissance d'un trappeur d'histoire
de l'art
notamment mona lisa ou bien
la vénus de botticelli ce sont des
chirurgies esthétiques
filmée en direct qui ont été enregistrés
sur vidéo mais aujourd'hui depuis depuis
1998 elle s'est adjoint les services la
technologie moderne a déclaré gilles
numérique pour poursuivre cette
recherche sur c'est une recherche
d'identité et l'identité de la femme
bien sûr et donc le traitement de
l'image le morphing en particulier là
nous avons un métissage complètement
improbable une femme mambe tout que l'on
reconnaît par
justement un cri un des critères de
beauté de ce peuple d'afrique centrale
qui est la déformation du crâne et cette
coiffure
de vannerie tressé et le profil de
l'euro stéphanoise aux relents elle même
qui né à saint-etienne et que l'on
reconnaît là
notamment par ses petites bosses sur les
tentes qu'ils sont
qui figurait déjà à l'époque de ces
chirurgies esthétiques des petites
petits implants de modifier son visage
et un autre critère
ce sont les bigoudis un qu'ils font
partie de la panoplie de beauté des
femmes occidentales
le visage est éminemment culturel et
c'est ce que nous dit cette cette image
en fait et l'artothèque et bien sûr très
fier de posséder cette oeuvre dans ses
collections qui permet aux abonnés qui
peuvent emprunter cette oeuvre d'avoir
chez soi une oeuvre de musées puisqu'un
autre exemplaire de ce cet autographe
figure dans le musée d'art contemporain
du val de marne à vitry sur seine